let's do a couple more rotational volume
problems and I'm going to make these a
little bit more difficult and hopefully
after these if you if you've understand
if you've understood everything we've
done up to now and the ones I'm about to
do I think you're you're pretty set for
most of what you should face in most
math classes and definitely I think
you'll be set for the AP exam and either
a B or B C on this concept so let's do
another example okay so let's say that I
want to actually let me do something
different we draw it here because so
that's my y-axis this is my x-axis now
let me draw the function y is equal to x
squared so let's say this is y is equal
to x squared and we know that that could
be written as y is equal to x squared or
we could write that as x is equal to
square root of Y depending on what we
want to be a function of what alright
this is the y-axis this is the x-axis
let's say I also have the line y equals
I don't know y equals let's say this
line y equals two it goes over what I
just wrote y equals two now this problem
is going to be slightly different than
what we've done so far so let's say I'm
going to take a rotation but instead of
taking a rotation around the Y or the x
axis I'm going to take a rotation around
another line so let's say I want to take
a rotation of let me pick pick the area
let me say between X is equal to zero
say X is equal to actually let me do
something arbitrary let me say between X
is equal to 1 so that's that point and X
is equal to 2 that's where they
intersect right this is the point right
here this is 2 to 2 comma 2 oh sorry no
2 comma 4 because Y is equal to x
squared so this is 2 comma 4 this is the
point 4
so what I want and what point is this
this is the point one right so our Y
values go from 4 to 1 or X values go
from 1 to 2 and that makes sense because
Y is x squared and so if we were to kind
of take the area that we're going to
rotate and haven't told you what we're
going to rotate it around yet and this
might prove to be shocking to you so
this is the area we're going to rotate
instead of rotating it around the y axis
I want to rotate it around the line y is
equal to minus 2 so I want to so if
that's 2 y equals -2 should be roughly
here so I'm going to rotate this area
let me around this line around this line
so what's that going to look like it's
going to be a fairly big ring like if I
were to if I were to try to draw it let
me see if I can even make an attempt
once again this is always the hardest
part just drawing what I'm trying to
rotate I'll try to do it from an upward
perspective so that's kind of the inner
loop and then there'll be an outer loop
the top is flat right because it's
defined by Y is equal to 4 so that's the
top the top is flat and the inside is
also going to be a hard edge right so
the inside is also going to be a hard
edge like that but then the outside is
going to curve inward I don't know if
you can if you see what I'm saying
because this is the outside it's curving
inward so it's a ring it's going to be a
big ring and what end so if I were to
draw the axis this this would be the Y
axis coming in no no sorry whoops
edit do the y axis is actually going to
be closer to this hand side right the Y
axis is going to be it's going to be in
the middle of kind of the so this is
going to be the y axis coming up here
right that's going to be the y axis and
then the x axis is going to come below
that I'm drawing everything at an angle
as best as I can the xxxx is going to
come below that and then this line but
we're rotating it around that's going to
be someplace over here that's going to
be the set whoops that's going to be
something like that just going to go
behind there and come back over there
hopefully that makes sense we're just
getting a big ring so how are we going
to do this well I think the easiest
thing to do well actually there's a
couple of things we can do first we
could just use the shell method using
the x-value so how do we do that
the important thing is to always
visualize the shell or the disk so the
shell method we're going to take slivers
like this right with where the width of
that sliver is DX I could draw it really
big so that's like the rectangle is
going to be DX the height what's the
height going to be of this sliver it's
going to be the top function minus the
bottom function it's going to be y
equals 4 minus x squared right so this
is going to be 4 minus x squared the
height at any point right here and then
if I were to do the shell just like we
did before let me see if I can draw a
decent shell I think I'm getting better
at this
see and then this is one edge of the
shell that's the other shell
what's the we already figured out that
the the width of the shell is DX the
height is 4 minus x squared right the
top function minus the bottom function
that tells you the distance between the
two and then what's the radius going to
be what's the radius of that shell going
to be well is it going to be just X is
it just going to be the x-value no the
x-value would tell you the distance from
the y axis to that shell and it's going
to be from minus 2 to the x value so
it's going to be essentially 2 plus X
all right that's going to be the radius
at any point and this is where we
diverged from what we've done before
before the radius was just X but now
it's 2 plus X so what's the
circumference of each shell going to be
well circumference is equal to 2 PI R
and our radius is 2 + X so it's 2 pi
times 2 plus X which equals 4 PI plus 4
PI + 2 pi X that's the circumference and
then what's the surface area of this
well it's going to be the circumference
times the height so surface area right
that area surface is equal to that the
circumference 4 PI + 2 pi X all of that
times the height times 4 minus x squared
and let's see if we can foil this out or
distribute this out so 4 pi times 4 is
16 pi 4 PI minus x squared minus 4 PI x
squared 2 pi X times 4 plus 8 PI X and
then 2 pi X times minus x squared so
that's minus 2 pi X to the third so
that's the surface area of each ring and
then if we want the volume of each shell
essentially we multiply it times the
width the DX DX and then if we want so
that's the volume of each shell and if
we want the volume of all the sad shells
we sum them up we sum them up so we take
the integral that's an integral sign I'm
running out of space like I always do
and where do I take the integral from or
take the integral from X is equal to 1/2
X is equal to 2 from 1 to 2 that's
probably too small for you to read 1 to
do so let's see if we can take the
antiderivative of this let me make some
space free just so I don't have to write
so small so I'll keep this down here
because we set the set up of the problem
and I think I can get rid of a lot of
this I think that is pretty good
okay and let me switch to another color
and we're ready to take the
antiderivative so what's the
antiderivative of this so the
antiderivative of 16 pi is 16 PI x 16 16
pi X and then what's the antiderivative
of a 4 PI x squared it's going to be X
to the third over 3 so it'll be minus 4
PI over 3 if sorry 4 PI over 3 X to the
third and then we have plus well this
will be x squared over 2 so it'll be
plus 4 PI x squared and then minus this
will be X to the fourth over 4 so minus
PI over 2 just divided by 4 X to the
fourth
I'm going to evaluate that this is a
much hairier problem than what we
wouldn't doing at 2 and at 1 so what is
it evaluated at 2 it is 32 pi minus 4 PI
over 3 times 8 plus 4 PI times 4 plus 16
PI - what's this to the fourth is 16
divided by 2 minus 8 pi and then I just
realize I'm running out of time so I
will continue this in the next video